tell you who loves horses oh potty mouth
andy mcdowell here
[Laughter]
you do you you genuinely love i do love
horses tell us how horses help you sleep
oh i i scroll horses before i go to bed
on instagram
to soothe and calm me down
yeah that's what i do and other people
but how do you find the horses on
instagram you just
i just put in horses up at the top
and i get a vast amount of all different
kinds of horses okay yeah and you just
scroll and scroll till
shut i come yeah that's how i do it okay
but i have a funny horror story if you
want to oh please
okay i love to ride how sweary is it
okay it doesn't swear but it's it's
funny i think
so i i love horses so much and i love to
ride bareback so at one point when i
left okay just like hold on
[Applause]
i lived in a really conservative
christian community in north carolina
that's where i raised my children and i
didn't know what i was saying i was very
naive about this i had an email address
that i used to communicate with the
school that was going i'm sorry
bareback shook
but i didn't i was i didn't know what it
meant
i just like to write beer bag and my
horse name was sugar it was bareback
sugar yeah there you go
i didn't know what it meant i was so
innocent i really didn't i didn't know
what to do well you know now they're
shook and i'm ascending it to the soul i
was communicating with the teachers good
for them
oh my god can you believe it yes i can
you know
[Music]